welcome to the realm where vigilance
meets Innovation where your resume
emerges as a testament to your cyber
security Acumen in an era defined by
persistent threats standing out
necessitates more than just knowledge it
demands tangible experience brace
yourself as we explore the top 10 cyber
security projects that will transform
your resume into a fortress of expertise
project one vulnerability assessment
tool a vulnerability assessment tool is
a computer security software application
that scans and tests a computer system
or network for potential vulnerabilities
and weaknesses vulnerability assessment
tools work by simulating attacks on a
system to identify any security holes
that could be exploited by attackers
imagine building a Cutting Edge tool
that prows networks fiting out
weaknesses with unparalleled Precision
craft a vulnerability assessment tool
that not only identifies potential
threats but also recommends robust
Solutions showcasing your adeptness in
preeptive threat mitigation project two
secure encryption algorithm secure
encryption algorithms are algorithms
used to encrypt data in such a way that
only authorized parties with a correct
key or password can access the
information
these algorithms are an important part
of digital security as they help to
protect sensitive data from unauthorized
access theft or disclosure what's cyber
security without an unbreakable
encryption Fortress design a
cryptographic Marvel that Shields
sensitive information from crying eyes
demonstrate your Mastery in safeguarding
data Integrity through an impervious
encryption algorithm project three
incident response simulation an incident
response simulation is a type of
security exercise that simulates a real
world incident response process the goal
of an incident response simulation is to
test an organization's ability to handle
a security incident by simulating a
realistic scenario and assessing how
effectively the organization can respond
to it dive into the world of Controlled
Chaos
develop an incident response plan that
Rivals a military strategy orchestrating
rapid responses to simulating cyber
threats showcase your ability to
navigate crisis scenarios with composure
and precision mitigating digital
disasters
effectively project four penetration
testing framework penetration testing
pen testing is a controlled simulation
of attacks on a computer system or
Network to identify vulnerability and
weaknesses in its security architecture
a penetration testing framework is a
systematic approach to pen testing that
defines the steps and processes to be
followed the objectives and scope of the
test and the tools and techniques to be
used the art of ethical hacking takes
Center Stage Forge of penetration
testing framework that not only
identifies system weaknesses but also
trans Ates them into strengths showcase
your progress in transforming
vulnerabilities into opportunities for
fortified defense project five security
automation script a security automation
script is a piece of code or a set of
instructions that can be executed on a
Computing system to automate security
related tasks and Operations Security
automation scripts are used to automate
repetive and routine security tasks to
centralize the management of security
controls and to improve security posture
by reducing the time and effort required
to perform security operations witness
the Symphony of automation develop a
script that cographs security protocols
reducing human error while amplifying
system efficiency illustrate your knack
for streamlining operations and
enhancing security through Innovative
automation project six blockchain
security implementation blockchain
security implementation is a set of
techniques and Technologies used to
secure blockchain networks and
applications typical blockchain security
implementation includes encryption
digital signatures Access Control
intrusion detection and prevention and
anti- malware mechanisms immerse
yourself in the enigmatic realm of
blockchain security Implement measures
that fortify decentralized systems
against tempering and unauthorized
access showcase your expertise in
securing the foundation of future
digital
Landscapes project seven iot device
security protocol iot device security
protocol is a set of guidelines and
practices that help device and sensors
in The Internet of Things iot
communicate securely it involves
securing communication between devices
protecting data from unauthorized access
and ensuring the confidentiality and
integrity of data navigate the complex
web of iot devices craft a security
protocol that safeguards interconnected
smart devices against potential
vulnerabilities illustrate your ability
to fortify the backbone of a connected
future project eight bug bounties and
hackathons
a bug Bounty is a program that allows
organizations to incentivize the
identification of security
vulnerabilities and bugs in their
systems and software typically through a
financial reward system companies often
offer bounties for the discovery and
reporting of vulnerabilities which may
include monetary rewards recognition or
other incentives the program encourages
ethical hackers security researchers and
other Security Experts to find and
Report vulnerabilities in a company's
systems and software you can showcase
your ability to find vulnerabilities in
the system through multiple interations
of cyber attacks project nine threat
intelligence platform a threat
intelligence platform is a
software-based system that collects
analyzes and distributes threat
intelligence data to organizations for
the purpose of protecting protecting
their systems and networks against cyber
attacks the platform provides realtime
insights into security threats allowing
organizations to take preventive and
responsive actions to mitigate risks
harness the power of information develop
a platform that Aggregates and analyzes
threat intelligence data showcase your
proactive approach to cyber security by
leveraging information for preemptive
defense against evolving
threats project 10 security audit and
compliance toolkit a security audit and
compliance tool kit is a software-based
solution that helps organizations to
improve their security and compliance by
automating the audit assessment and
Reporting process the toolkit offers
various features such as asset Discovery
vulnerability scanning compliance
reporting and incident response help
helping organizations to protect their
systems and data from cyber threats
enter the realm of compliance and
standards create a comprehensive toolkit
that simplifies security Audits and
ensures compliance with stringent cyber
security standards illustrate your
Proficiency in maintaining regulatory
requirements and upholding best
practices these top 10 cyber security
projects aren't mere accomplishments
they are Testaments to to your
commitment to safeguarding digital
Landscapes elevate your career by
showcasing these projects signaling that
you're not just a cyber security
Enthusiast but a stalwart guardian of
digital
Integrity staying ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upscaling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here